[موسيقى]
لطالما كان الجنوب الأمريكي يتذوق
الطعام المكسيكي ، لكن أحد الطهاة
ابتكر مزيجًا فريدًا من
تغيير وقته ، كان علينا أن نفعل شيئًا
مختلفًا ، ولا أفقد الحقيقة أو
التركيز الذي أتيت إليه من المكسيك
أريد أن أتأكد من أن الطعام
يعكس ماضي في الحاضر ، والسماء هي
الحد الأقصى
الذي يمكننا القيام به ما نريده ، اسمي
سارة هيرنانديز ، الشريك في ملكية
تيكيلا في سيول والشيف التنفيذي
إيدي جاء إلى الولايات المتحدة وهو مراهق في
1974 مع مائة وأربعين
دولارًا فقط في جيبه ، استغرق الأمر مني ثلاث
سنوات للانتقال من عامل التنظيف إلى
المدير العام للمطعم اليوم
وهو يدير سلسلة من المطاعم في
جورجيا وتينيسي
ويعود نجاحه بلا شك إلى نهجه الذكي في
كل طبق أنا طعام مختلف أصنع
شيئًا مختلفًا دون
أن أفقد طعم المكان الذي أتيت منه
[الموسيقى]
بينما تستخدم العمة المكونات
الأصلية للمكسيك ،
فهو يبقي الحنك الأمريكي في الاعتبار
، لقد قررت أن أفعل ذلك  شيء
في سيدها باستخدام صلصة تاباسكو
مع الفلفل الحريف ، قررت استخدام
الفلفل الصحيح وهو عبارة عن فلفل حار متوفر
في نفس العائلة التي يرغبون في وضع
خرطوم بها لحم الخنزير والتي اعتقدت أنهم ينقرون عليها ،
لذلك أستخدم مرق الدجاج الذي
يحبونه  تناوله مع خبز الذرة أحب
تناوله مع خبز التورتيلا واليوم
يتعلم الناس تناول اللفت الأخضر مع
التورتيلا لأنك تعطي نكهة الذرة على
أي حال لـ Eddie - يستغرق وقتًا
وتجريبًا ولكن النتيجة النهائية
تستحق العناء دائمًا
يمكنني تذوق المكونات و  ثم
اكتشفت كيف يمكنني الحصول على أفضل نكهة في
ثقافة القرص في هذه الثقافة وهذه
الثقافة لإنشاء منتج جديد
ونكهة جديدة يمكنك وضعها في اليابان
وسأقوم بطهي الطعام المكسيكي في اليابان
وأستراليا ، لا يهم  بالنسبة لي ،
يعتبر الطعام انعكاسًا لمكان
انعكاس لمن نحن ومن أتينا
وأعتقد أن الطعام هو المكون الوحيد
الذي يمكنهم من خلاله جمع قادة الحرب
معًا أكثر من طاولة واحدة في تصادم
[موسيقى]
أنت